the hogwarts legacy news train continues
to roll on today playstation put up a
new blog post as well as a short video
on the exclusive features coming to the
ps5 version of hogwarts legacy thanks to
the dual sense controller however
regardless of which console or pc you'll
be playing on you want to make sure you
stick around because there is something
in here for everybody we're gonna break
it all down here right now in today's
video so you can head on over to the
playstation blog and you'll find a post
from chandler wood the hogwarts legacy
community manager the title how hogwarts
legacy taps ps5 features to make
gameplay feel
magical now you guys know i'll always
keep it real with you we're gonna try
and separate the marketing speak here
from what may actually have an influence
on your gameplay so here at the top the
sense wireless controller connects you
directly with your wand immersing you in
visuals and sound yeah marketing speak
right there with hogwarts legacy we
wanted to immerse you in the wizarding
world like never before want in hand
nothing is more important at avalanche
software than making sure players feel
like they are living in this world
playstation 5 allows us to take that
immersion further as you build a legacy
of your own also by the way i think this
yet again confirms that playstation does
have some sort of marketing exclusivity
deal with hogwarts legacy no that does
not mean it is exclusive to playstation
people always ask that when i make that
comment it is instead just referring to
the marketing for the game so
playstation will always have their logo
featured on anything with hogwarts
legacy at least for the early part of
the game we don't know what those
contract terms look like however first
little heading here connect with your
wand a witch or wizard should never be
without their wand and the playstation
5's dualsense wireless controller
becomes an extension of your one and
hogwarts legacy with so many spells at
your disposal the adaptive triggers
allow for more flexibility in combat
okay this one right here is where i
think we may have our first component of
something that will actually affect your
gameplay now i have a ps5 and i gotta
say i've been kind of disappointed with
how few games actually take advantage of
these adaptive triggers because i
promise you guys that piece at least
when it comes to the adaptive triggers
is not marketing it is kind of insane
how these things work you guys i'll try
and show you here a little bit on screen
hold halfway down what
oh my goodness dude this
the ps5 controller if you haven't tried
one yet it is so trippy
how these triggers can alternate
it's like i'm i'm pressing halfway down
on the trigger and it's like i feel
feedback that it's stopping two games
that i have personally played that take
great advantage of these controllers are
eternal as well as astros playroom which
is just a complete incredible showcase
for the entire dual sense controller but
the reason these are called adaptive
triggers is that the resistance can
actually change if you haven't played
with the ps5 controller then it is truly
i gotta say this is one of those things
that the first time you try it really
will kind of blow your mind in terms of
how it can totally feel like a normal
trigger and then all of a sudden you
press it and you barely press it down
and you're feeling resistance there
eternal uses this to great effect you'll
feel the magical resistance at your
fingertips through every spell whether
firing off a basic cast or summoning the
strength of a more powerful charm okay
we're kind of back to the marketing
stuff here spells will feel unique when
you cast them thanks to haptic feedback
providing a direct connection between
the dualsense controller and your wand
now when it comes to haptic feedback
certainly not anything new there the
dualsense certainly does have some nice
haptic feedback features though and when
you continue reading here it says we've
specifically isolated these effects to
the right side of the controller to let
the dual sense become an extension of
the ones you hold in the game so what
that means for left-handed players
though and when you deflect a spell with
protego you'll feel the sizzling of the
magic being reflected and absorbed by
the shield charm so kind of summing up
all of this right here basically what i
think they're saying is that based on
the type of spell you're using you're
going to feel a different sort of
haptics and then because it seems like
our wizard is going to be right-handed
it looks like the feeling of the spell
casting will actually be focused mainly
on the right side of the controller
adaptive triggers and haptic feedback
aren't just limited to spell casting and
wand work however the dual sense
controller lets you feel a variety of
events throughout the world whether it's
crushing ingredients with a mortar and
pestle and potions class feeling the
screech of a mandrake seedling or flying
through the skies on a broom or
hippogriff the dualsense is your
connection to the magic on ps5 so mostly
kind of marketing stuff here i don't
think there's anything too crazy about
this basically they're just talking
about the rumble and the haptics that
you're going to be feeling when you're
doing things like mixing potions or
flying on a broom or hypocrite now they
also did include some very brief
glimpses at new footage of the game that
we haven't seen before let me go ahead
and hit the hd button right here so this
is going to improve the quality for you
here nice shot here of the spell casting
and looks like protego being cast notice
the r1 over here we talked about that
some with the other trailer how it seems
like r1 kind of pops up indicating that
there is some sort of item you can
interact with i think it looks like
there's a little barrel behind this guy
by the way not sure but is now the time
we should start worrying about the ai in
this game i mean look at this guy he
just got to keeps walking into this tree
here doesn't seem to know it's there
again though to be fair this is not
finalized and it could very well be on
the easiest difficulty i don't know but
hopefully we don't see stuff like that
in the final game we've also tapped into
the dual sense controller's light to
give you a unique bit of personalization
when not flashing along with spells
being cast or damage being taken the
dual sense controller lights will pulse
with the colors of your hogwarts house
blue and bronze for ravenclaw scarlet
and gold for gryffindor green and silver
for slytherin and yellow and black for
hufflepuff i love this this is such a
nice touch even though i don't
personally like the dual senses light
bar very much i will say it's an
improvement over the ps4 version but
primarily i just find their a battery
suck honestly you don't really look down
at the controller while you're playing
so while it's a fun little thing for me
personally i don't think it's a big deal
i actually have my dual sense light as
dim as it will possibly go to save as
much battery life as i possibly can
alright we come to a new section here
sights and sounds of hogwarts visually
we've come a long way since the days of
the beloved hagrid on the original
playstation you're a wizard hogwarts
legacy on ps5 lets you take in hogwarts
and the surrounding area in stunning 4k
as well as a choice between fidelity and
performance graphics modes yes this is
the big news for me in this whole entire
piece fidelity and performance modes
confirmed i think this is a great
addition to the game most likely i will
be playing on the performance mode
because give me that silky silky smooth
frame rate baby this choice will allow
you to create your preferred experience
whether that's prioritizing a higher
frame rate or visual fidelity the ps5
console's tempest 3d audio tech will put
you right in the heart of the wizarding
world hear the crackle of fire as you
cast incendio potions bubbling and
cauldrons and the uniquely detailed
soundscapes of each environment to
really make you feel present and if you
play without headphones you'll be
treated to additional immersive sounds
through the dual sense controller
speaker like the soft flap of a
hippogriff's wings and effects of each
spell you cast again all this sounds
nice but i don't think xbox or pc
players are really going to be missing
out on anything here next paragraph
additionally expect the playstation 5's
ultra high speed ssd to provide quick
loading times no matter how you choose
to move from place to place whether you
take the scenic route on a broom or fast
travel via the flu network confirmation
of the flu network by the way even
though we've kind of already figured it
out we'll also support the ps5's
activity cards and game help features
we're thrilled to connect you with the
wizarding world in a more immersive way
than ever before thanks to the ps5 and
dual since controller when hogwarts
legacy launches holiday 2022 again that
holiday 2022 confirmation now when it
comes to the ssd i will say that this is
a big deal as well the ps5 has
incredible incredible load time so it's
really nice to see this here one
question i do have is they talk about
load times and then they talk about
whether you take the scenic route on a
broom so i hope that doesn't mean that
we're gonna be see loading times when
we're actually flying through the world
fast travel i totally get but when we're
flying through the world on a broom or
going from room to room please please i
cannot take the old days of the harry
potter chamber of secrets where you open
a door and you have to wait for every
single room to load please don't do that
to us avalanche so what do you guys
think about these ps5 exclusive features
let me know in the comments below which
console or pc that you plan to play the
game on as always thank you all so much
for watching i'll talk to you again soon